appreciate you coming in and doing this
podcast
you're from the area clearwater right
well i'm originally from australia
oh yeah i'm originally australian but i
live here
in palm harbor now which is just for
people not in this area it's just north
of clearwater okay
and when i first came to the united
states in 1975
when scientology first moved into
clearwater
obviously i lived here okay and then i
spent a lot of time in los
angeles but okay so you you were
uh just for people out there who may not
know your story
um you were one of the top senior
executives at the church of scientology
um number two to david miscavige i
believe
you were pretty high up there right
really close to him for a long time
and why don't you just go ahead and give
us like a
like a brief background of how you got
started in all this
well i got started through my parents i
was introduced to scientology when i was
six years old by my parents in australia
and i was really raised as a
scientologist
and when i graduated high school i
joined the sea organization which is
scientology's uh inner
core of most dedicated elite
members it's sort of like the the uh
vatican i guess or you know some very
very hardcore you sign a billion year
contract and
dedicate yourself to achieving the aims
of scientology
and i went
initially to join el run hubbard the
founder of scientology
on his boat in the mediterranean which
was called the apollo
and hubbard had left england
and was being pursued by various
government agencies and he decided
in 1966 67
that he was going to sort of escape
government oversight
and he bought three ships
and the largest of them was called the
apollo and he hung out on the apollo and
sail around in the mediterranean
and then ultimately into the caribbean
and
that was the people from
the apollo in the caribbean who then
moved ashore here to clearwater in late
1974 early 1975
and i was with hubbard throughout that
time period and then when we came to
clearwater or when we came
ashore from the apollo i was actually
one of the very first people that came
to the fort harrison
i was there when it was still the
jacktar hotel before
scientology had taken possession of it
um wow i sort of rose in the ranks of
scientology
ultimately to become the international
spokesperson for scientology
on the board of directors of the church
of scientology international
which is the mother church of
scientology and the head
of what's known as the office of special
affairs and the office of special
affairs
is a very euphemistic sounding or very
euphemistic name
for the department of scientology that
deals with external matters
which includes external threats which
means taking care of the enemies of
scientology
right and that
uh history when elrond hubbard died
in 1986 there was a a sort of a
vacuum created he didn't leave any
specific clear instructions about what
was to happen after he croaked
and david miscavige the current leader
of scientology
ultimately prevailed in a sort of power
struggle
and took over and has followed in the
footsteps of hubbard since then
so initially i worked for hubbard but
then
i started working for miscavitch when he
took over
and i was uh along with another guy
called marty rathbun
sort of the two uh people who dealt with
all external matters for scientology
the irs exemption dealing with
governments
dealing with legal cases with the media
with all all anything that had to do
with
scientology's um relationship to the
world
and the difficulties that may be having
pr wise or legal wise
wow so what was it like being around
l ron hubbard and how old were you at
that time um i was
18 when i first arrived i just turned 18
when i first arrived
on the apollo with hubbard um
he was a very
larger than life character he was
um he was a large man
just physically but he was also
had this this sort of commanding
presence
of you know you knew when he walked in a
room
even if you didn't see him he was just
a big uh
narcissistic but somewhat humorous
but crazy but
super smart but like this the enigmas
surrounding l ron hubbard uh are kind of
hard to
to describe there is a very very
brilliant book
written by uh an english author called
russell miller
that is an unauthorized biography of el
ron hubbard
and that book um
bare-faced messiah is
the best insight into the life of
hubbard hubbard was
a at heart he was a bullshitter
he was a storyteller he made his living
writing fiction works science fiction
and other sorts of pulp fiction
and he basically took his skill
as a writer of fiction
and turned it into a money-making
proposition
as the author of scientology
and you know there are things in
scientology
that are um
that that most people would agree with
it's not all
nuts right like there's enough of it
that
is sort of makes sense and
and does help some people and is
pretty benign and
interesting what's sort of interesting
about it is how cleverly
it is constructed to have
a sort of a face to the world and a
presentation to new people that makes it
kind of attractive and interesting and
only
once you've immersed yourself in it more
do you start to see the darker side
right but yeah it seems like it in
at least for face value it seems like a
very productive
get [ __ ] done you know get rid of the
negative influences
influences in your life and it's a very
positive way to
you know be a better version of yourself
in all aspects at least for face value
well that's what it promotes
right and there is and like i said there
is
there are aspects to it that are
presented to the world
that make it appear that way the
unfortunate truth is that there is a
very
dark underbelly to scientology and
you know that's what we really covered
in the aftermath series that leah remini
and i did
and now we are covering on the podcast
that we are doing
which is called scientology fair game
and fair
game is the the real
meat of the nasty business of
scientology
because fair game is the policy
and practices that were laid out by el
ron hubbard
to destroy enemies
and danny you wouldn't believe
the detail that he went into
on how you go about doing that and this
is all
written in documents that are
avail you know they're not readily
available
they're much more available now
wikileaks has got a bunch of them i've
got a bunch of them on my blog
they're uh they've sort of leaked out
over the years but
these are documents that say basically
to
harass intimidate uh trick
lie destroy enemies
and enemies is i i put in
quotation marks because in
the scientology or the hubbard
definition of enemy as anybody who
disagrees with questions opposes
or criticizes scientology in any way
it's not you know you don't have to be
a uh an out-and-out
criminal to be designated an
enemy of scientology
i